so who knew that calling the cops when
your family is threatened comes from a
place of privilege what if in the middle
of the night my home is broken into who
do I call yes I mean I hear that loud
and clear from a lot of my neighbors and
I know and myself too and I know that
that comes from a place of privilege
what an idiot
that was the president of the
Minneapolis City Council who's planning
a formal vote to defund the police so
after days of unrest that's their next
step if you do not believe that we are
in the middle of a mass delusion where
humanity is willfully rejecting what
works for what destroys I don't think I
can help you but if you can't beat the
mob why not help them let's defund but
baby steps first it's too expensive to
start from scratch and create a police
free city so let's pick two cities and
observe the outcomes because the
Minneapolis City Council is voting to
defund already let's go with them first
and for comparison let's do Hollywood
where some celebs who signed an open
letter demanding defunding actually live
the comparison eliminates race from the
equation and sits it squarely on
something else
wealth in class while citizens of
Minneapolis will fall prey to chaos and
roving gangs of violence last week being
the prequel Hollywood will rely on
private security which many of its
fabulous inhabitants already enjoy it's
why John Legend and others see no
problem in defunding because it won't be
a problem for them at least with
Minneapolis the hard left zombies on
that council are ready to see their
delusions through citizens be damned or
killed
let's see Hollywood do the same thing
and when the rich do fine while the poor
suffer maybe that injustice will be
televised too in color not just black
and white so Dana here's it here's a
question if we can define the police
which we believe you we used to believe
they were essential to governance
why can't of the entire cover government
be defunded because what's more
essential that the police it's not our
senators it's not our congressmen why
not across the board do you think about
the governor
remember back in I think junior high
back in our day you learned Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and what is the very
first need on which everything else
depends security okay so there's one
thing that we all learned way back by
learning kindergarten - the other thing
is Minneapolis has said that it needs
about forty five million dollars they're
asking the federal government for help
to deal with all the damage that
happened but why should the federal
government provide Minneapolis with that
kind of support if they're gonna try
this experiment of dismantling the
police I think that the federal
government should probably wait on that
the other thing reg that I thought was
pretty interesting is that you'll see
that the media some in the media are
already trying to help the the left deal
with this defund the police slogan
they're saying well it actually needs
more context it doesn't actually mean
that okay well where have we seen this
before
it's like when they put out the green
new deal and it was like they want to do
what and then well actually know what it
really means is they're just gonna
tinker around the edges
what about believe all women oh wait no
we don't do that either yeah and then
what was the other one I thought about
the Oh ban corporate money from
campaigns and yet they all take the
corporate money so at some point the
progressive left is gonna figure out
that the establishment Democrats are
just ignoring all of their slogans
partly because they're nonsensical but
also because they don't believe them
right you know what it is John Oliver
has become the spokesperson for the
Cathedral he's the one that is how
explaining all of these issues as not
really being what they are so when you
hear one you hear defund the police
which sounds incredibly unreasonable and
stupid then they retreat to a position
that sounds reasonable by comparison
it's a very sneaky strategy oh we don't
mean that we
shifting it to to the youth at risk
we're just sifting funds around but
that's not what they originally said
they're doing this they're doing this by
cover and I know you agree huh no I was
thinking of myself wait a minute so
something like I think by the way defund
the police makes no sense to me so I
just I can't I reject that out of hand
but I hear the slogan thank God I hear
the slogan much much like I hear the
slogan you know build a wall drain the
swamp on the right it stirs up the
right-wing base it never happens it's
not going to happen but this stirs up
summon the political extremes okay well
you know to me it's a non-starter be go
please Thank You Jesse I hope you
believe that but it seems to me there
are like and she was my own eyes that we
can't yeah I see it too I can see right
through it in fact but I think that what
we can embrace and you know it's it's
now it's not just far left it's like 60%
of Americans say that the police use
excessive force in dealing with black
Americans you hear a very conservative
Senator Lindsey Graham saying there's a
problem here and so in this
congressional bill that was put forward
today you see some realistic reforms
that are embraced or can be embraced by
the likes of me anyway things like bands
on choke holes increased use of the
cameras the the body cameras and the
like no more no-knock warrants like
resulted in the death of Brianna Taylor
these are logical and good steps and the
idea that you would have more officers
taken away from dealing with people who
have mental issues or drug problems or
youth that that that needs help it seems
to me those are rational good steps for
America to take yeah the only problem is
is that nobody's actually helping the
mentally ill at least in our cities and
police are often left with that burden I
would like it shifted to mental health
professionals but that never happens
Katie if we actually did well you're
glad you're going up side to this yeah
the upside Katie
you know there's an upside the
privatization and then the fact that we
could roll back gun control laws because
if we're no longer being protected we
got to protect ourselves what in Greg
doesn't that really expose the way that
they operate I mean it's just so
illogical so first they advocate for gun
control so that you can't defend
yourself and tell you to call the police
so once then they've just armed you they
then get rid of the police department
and say that you're on your own and that
if you call the police it's part of your
white privilege and therefore you
essentially deserved whatever was going
to happen to you when someone broke into
your house late at night so that's the
the first problem I have some friends
longtime friends Justice Andrews their
show in Minneapolis of a local radio
show they call it the Minnesota City
Council for this very reason
but the bigger picture here is but this
isn't about justice but yeah the City
Council this isn't about justice this is
about social justice and you have to
think about what this means police are
there to enforce the laws that are
passed by representatives whether it's
the state level or the federal level
those representatives are voted into
office by the American people by
citizens who choose who their leaders
are to put those laws on the books if
you don't have police enforcing the laws
then everything is up for grabs in terms
of people's feelings what is actually
justice based on skin color in class and
nobody is actually equal under the law
anymore so this is a bigger question of
what is the end goal here of tearing
down the entire system not just quote
defunding the police or implementing
some kind of reform if you don't have
please to enforce the laws that are
passed by representatives of the people
and then everything starts to break down
pretty quickly yeah you know Jesse it's
no surprising that the it is the left
the left side of the government that
only is dealing with one half of the
equation the police that's they're gonna
solve the police problem but not the
criminal problem they don't see that if
you just remove that you the criminal
problem actually gets worse yeah I mean
everybody sees that except well I won't
name names but just to mention something
Juan brought up 450 miles of the border
has been built according to Politico mr.
Williams also yes the swamp is being
drained
that's why Comey and all his merrie very
go wits got fired okay now the real
point is this might be the dumbest take
take a position that the whole country
agrees with that this death of George
Floyd was a horrible thing and then do
three somersaults backwards into a
position that 90% of the country
disagrees with defund the police Dana's
right they did it with the environment
everybody wants clean air and water but
they say let's spend a hundred trillion
and ban airplanes they did it with what
they've done it with everything and so
so if you take away the police who's
gonna protect the cities the guys with
the guns who has the guns the gangs have
the guns so you're going now have to pay
a fee for a gang to protect you it's
called a protection racket that's what
happens and all of the people that are
calling the police
when their homes burglarized who are
they going to send not a police officer
they're sending a social worker that's
in the fine print of this defund the
police movement whatever that's going to
do and if you look at the police in
terms of these inner city's a majority
the police officers are actually black
in a lot of these big cities and a lot
of the police chief's in these cities
are black too and aware of the union
dues go from the police unions they go
to Democrats so the Democrats are just
hurting themselves with this politically
and in terms of Public Safety and if
they want to go let them do it because
everyone's just gonna flee the cities
and buy guns the two things Democrats
say they don't want to have happen all
right Greg can I make one point sure I
just wanted to remind everybody and so
in New York City mayor de Blasio is
saying that he is going to reduce
funding for the police and he wants to
put it into more things like education
dealing with mental health but if you'll
remember it was actually the New York
City government itself that had to admit
that deblasio's education program of
which they spent almost a billion
dollars they can't figure out any
program that actually was benefited from
that or did better and also when his
wife did all of that work on mental
health they had to admit that they
basically wasted a billion dollars on
that too so I'm not sure that New York
should fall for that yeah I think he's
going to still keep the police detail
when he goes to his gym in Brooklyn
probably the worst mayor in the history
of the world